gotham wants bullets
okay if levy wants bullets
what's levi's username i haven't played
levy
on leachat in a while
we actually we had a match back in 2020
it was a platform battle match where
we had half of it on leachates and half
of it on chess.com
[Music]
and i was streaming it from his
apartment
and he he beat me
wait
oh that's my yeah
magnus isn't actually challenging me
okay
hey i'm playing levy
[Music]
oh no my exams should study for them
okay
ah he's playing
what is this
i just wasted a tempo
oh i should uh move quicker
let's actually focus
because this could this could be
somewhat competitive
where's my night move
i feel stuck
i feel like a hermit crab
this is a terrible setup
but maybe it's somewhat solid
i'm curious how lovely we'll be in the
time scrambles
i'm currently down on time
oh my bishop
do i dirty flag the legend
the internet's chess teacher
ah he's so tricky
no
good game okay
no more mercy
let's play in england
are we gonna repeat the same opening
oh we have a reverse slav now
yeah this opening preparation is not the
most impressive
okay let's just try and get an early
time advantage and not plunger
okay can't complain with this
b5
knight
play b5
knight belongs on d5
oh
i forgot levy's actually kind of good at
chess
okay so if takes a fork
and then oh no both of our
[Music]
i'm queens sure if this works though
because knight b7
my b7 is actually a big problem
um i'm gonna be down a piece
however i'm up on time
i have some weird compensation
g5
interesting play rook f
here we go 5 g4 right d5
there we go
ah confusing rooks
rooks are so tricky
oh no
okay
i'm slightly disappointed we drew based
on him flagging rather than stalemate
but
it was going to be stalemate eventually
right
uh he's not pre-moving e6
i was expecting the e6 b6 course but
i'll have to wait
okay let's try and win a game
the first step to winning is drawing
and some knight d5
be careful of tactics
so if my king were still on g1 there was
knight f3
at least leachates is working now
[Music]
kind of
that's a good move
oh
[Music]
not feeling so great about this position
anymore
take and maybe take
don't maybe
okay i want to play this and then this
and then this
thank you tico six months
cheers to eric the mr rogers cheers of
chess
thanks so much
i don't know what to do here
yeah he's so fast i forgot he's so fast
okay
oh london time okay
these games should not come down to the
time scrambles
to preserve more time
ah okay
yeah he has a recap video where he shows
this line
a6b5 i guess
yeah this is already
nice for black
but you never know
okay
i want to play e5
that's a good move
in rosen let's go
down on time again
what is this
i don't know what to do now
i can make a passport
interesting
i have no time
five thousand two hundred and eighty
viewers new record in rosen let's go oh
no my pawn thing
oh my thing
oh wow oh thank you awk
okay
uh let's um
wait he plays candy
let's try and move quicker and play
stronger
i've not won a single game against levy
idea h5
okay makes me happy
a3
probably won the queensland castle two
knight d5
94.
okay g6 is now weak
idea queen f2
ooh tricky
very tricky
okay i should be pretty happy here
actually
f7
i lose g2 but i have the now outside
past h pawn
um
[Music]
it's a really annoying move
be careful not to get mated
oh the position was really winning until
i flagged
ah
hey it's ben feingold what's up
environment
okay
no more losing
also what is this opening
there's a b4
okay c3 is very tender
idea this and
this okay the comeback has to start
somewhere
position looks really really good but
my confidence is not that great right
now
[Music]
okay thankfully
everything's defended i'd knight c2
uh play knight c2
ah then knight c3
hitting all the major pieces
there we go
[Music]
yeah i think beating hikaru made me
overconfident
what is this
he's being tricky again
oh no
there we go
okay let's go
i want a game
can i make it two
he's gonna play a five i think
hey it's katie what's up caddy
thanks cuddy
if you're just joining i'm playing
gotham chess
we're playing a bullet match
he's up four and a half one and a half
he wants to hurt me
yeah everyone should follow teddy
met her in dubai
had some fun
some fun outings in dubai
what is this position
um
i think i'll just sack and um
try and not get mated
king g1 i'm gonna have knight c7
or not
i have this idea now
okay so i'm of a pawn
hi eric
long time no see hey leo leo friggum
how's it going
good to see you
there we go
let's go okay two in a row it's gonna be
a streaky match probably
the e6
yeah we played this in the speedchest
championship
for iams
threatening to take in knight d4
i just blunder upon
maybe not
how'd it do this
confusing position
97
[Music]
f5 is it's a risky move but i think it
was called for
let's play this
position's not great but
there's still some life in it
i don't want to get into a time scramble
again
oh yes my prime
oh thank you
no that was a mouse up
ah it's almost still made if the rook
takes the pawn
what to do okay
uh let's play e4 again
what was he playing against e4 oh it's a
french
it's ortho snap time
uh this might be an ortho schnapp gone
very wrong but we'll see
it's already kind of a funny looking
position
queen c
queen e3
i have three center pawns
f5 okay
oops
i should play d3 there
thinking about this idea
never mind
so turning this and this
check
okay position's looking good there's no
rookie eight can take that
or got7 is now a threat
also this is a threat
defending
winning a queen
[Music]
okay three and a half five and a half it
tries to come back
um
the other three is considered dubious
because of this but
not sure how great this line actually is
for black
i just blunder the bishop
okay he misses queen a4
uh
can i take this
maybe we need seven coming
knight will return
he wanted to play rookie one but
that's kind of backfiring
now threatening e3
yeah i got skewered but i'm counter
attack
not a great way to defend d4
if here i have c5
this pawn is pinned
yeah now i'm trying to take and win the
bishop
uh i guess there's this move
and then rook b3 okay i'll play bishop
g6
so queen attacks
very clever play
calculation on passant and then take
or maybe take with rook
what is this
bishop takes my mate
this works there we go
okay that's cool
good good says ben feingold
okay four and a half four and a half
look at this
feingold also says watching ims dot dot
dot sigh
i should sigh more
i feel like sighing will lower my heart
rate
can be a good
strategy especially as i got older
uh what to do 95
queen h5
okay so the queen found a nice home
f4
i just want to make all of my pieces
happy
bishop the other rook
okay i might be losing material but
maybe it's okay
i'm going to move a lot faster
a little bit too slow
[Music]
kh1 probably will be useful at some
point
interesting
some funny pawn structure
yeah there's no infiltration points for
the rook
at least for the black rook
and his pawns are so funny oh
now they're less funny
i go for a dirty
flag i kinda have to
no
rook b6 preventing king b4
oh i'm so salty now
okay let's play um
[Music]
what's this
it's a playable line
i'm trying to play aggressively here
94 is kind of a threat
okay this looks reasonable
c5
hear this move
yeah the dream is to fork on f3 but i
have to remove the bishop first
which is difficult
i just blundered two pawns
you only took one of them
almost remove the wrong move there
wow
draw
wait no draw
draw
draw okay
i'm not going for a dirty flag
okay
five to seven that's somewhat close
oh i should have a chat room open
in case he wants to communicate with me
oh thank you mr pogzilla
you're so kind
he might play a hippo again
[Music]
uh c3
not sure why i was pausing there
i don't know which animal is 10 months
but i guess i'm a twitch that baby good
luck
yeah which animal has a 10 month
gestation period
okay uh let's try and stay focused here
i have my knights
i have to hold my horses
and this pawns are goner
maybe this pawn too
or this pawn
and get the other rook involved
yeah that's tricky
okay i was expecting a fight there but
c4 again let's play something new
play a four nights
english
okay king's indian style
i don't usually play king's indian
but now i'm playing a king's indian
trick is to check me on the king side
it's an interesting move
i think this is actually okay
is that bishop d8 in the end
yeah he was expecting rook d8 but
it was worth a calculation there
i wonder what levy is doing right now
okay
seven seven
uh
play d4 again
yeah f5
i'll play this line against dutch
take
oops
whoa queen f4
this opening crap
it might be
uh check there there
this is probably a bad decision
[Music]
or a good decision
threatening maiden one
look at this move
ah i'm losing a bishop though
or am i
wait what's going on
it's imbalanced
never too late to castle queenside
what is this position
c3 probably coming next
not sure if the rook trade helps me or
him but
oh i lost a pawn
[Music]
play b4 first
before preventing a5 but
a good move
what's going on
ah
that was a cool game too wow what a game
play at walrus now
oh what is knight g one
what is knight g one
okay i do a knight h4
white's position is so solid
trying to find a breakthrough point
this h3 is kind of clever
okay let's have a party on the king side
idea to trap the rook
rook is now trapped
okay keep things defended
this is why i like playing levy
and getting positions like this
so much fun
but he still sometimes beats me even
from positions like this
let's make a queen
uh take that
well does this move
let's take a thing
i feel scared now
don't hurt me
oh no there's a bishop on a1
[Music]
no
my queen wait
am i still alive
well this game
[Music]
oh i got mated
how do you win from that position
oh
that game
your sweet chess streams motivate me to
work oh it's kind of walrus
yeah we are the walrus hacking
thank you mk smoke
okay idea to take on g6
i gotta do it it was too tempting
rick g i didn't i didn't see
but i think it's okay
queen e6 in the end
maybe queen here h pawns
and the e pawn are both hanging
he wants to make me on e2 but i can
castle
[Music]
another position like the same kind of
style
[Music]
okay i'm threatening mates in one two
three
no just two one two
or one two
okay that was a fun game
oh we're close to the same rating
oh b3
okay so one of these lines which i think
are
oh it's going to be crazy again
can i smother me him
let's
try so the goal is
oh
i didn't see that move
uh i guess i can take this
okay so that was one big trade
we're probably trading queens
maybe i win a pawn
but maybe i don't
it's debating whether to take on g6
okay preserving the bishop i think i can
take this
die blunder the pawn
or did i
uh
[Music]
this should be a draw but who knows
he might play for a win
i'm gonna play for a win
let's go
[Music]
okay that was a kind gift
it's turning into a close match
[Music]
i don't know what we're playing to
though
you guys know what we were playing too
oh yeah feel free to update the stream
title
um
match versus gotham chess or something
i think mods have that ability levy said
a hundred
wait but i have a meeting later
100 games is a lot
and make for good youtube content though
okay this is already looking really
really really nice
got my pawns smiling got my queen
joining the party
i always play king b1
not sure if ben feingold's still
watching but
it's dedicated to ben
okay
i always play f62 right
f6 bam
hey it's my first lead in the match
let's go
let's go
i need to hire a butler to bring me tea
uh
i just make tea like two hours ago and
then
i got distracted
i wanted to play the jonathan transcon
gambit
yo
i'll play a6
yeah this this match could use some more
gambits actually
it'll play c5 and knight c6
might be some greek gift idea why not
okay so the question is how to
how to continue
this may have been a bad sacrifice
i think i can try this and then rookie 8
and some eventual this move
ah the queen h1
it's still interesting
took too much time there though
position's paying off
my position is really paying off
am i winning
i was completely winning
somehow this worked
queen b1 is now a may threat
they use someone
oh he wants to dirty flag me
okay
the dirty maid is better is more
powerful than the dirty flag
okay let's play some gambits
kerokan
[Music]
oh let's play this line
h5 what is h5
what is h5 h4 maybe
i wanted to play e6
i'll play e6
ooh
[Music]
okay queen here threatening this goal of
losing a knight
got overconfident
and a bit negligent too
but we'll keep fighting
black has double pawns
that's my compensation
oh
he's so tricky
but i'm also tricky no i'm not tricky
okay
i got forked
play this line again
ah
wait we have an exchange slave
i don't really play the exchange slave
it's not a great position
but i did win connect for
am i losing a queen
at b6
that's so sad my queen's trapped
wait no i have queen d2
but then roxy too ah
and then this
i lost a piece
okay let's try and fight back
on passant
i get my rooks involved
i do h4
this actually doesn't seem so so bad
put a rook on the dark square
f4 is coming
doh
now it's so so bad
okay
well we're tied now again
i'll play in english again
i have to revert to more serious
openings
oh my watch is about to die
i haven't really checked my heart rate
for this match
i don't think my heart rate's gonna
exceed what it hit earlier
i think that's a mouse slip by him
yeah i want to play f4
[Music]
get the chance
queen d3 maybe some idea
[Music]
we see five knives
hitting this and this
yeah it's not quite what i wanted
really
oh let's not plunder a queen
a g-pawn is very tender looking this
g-pawn
very tender looking
i can take this
let's take here first
i have to win f3
okay
i finally flagged him in like a time
scramble thing
okay i'm gonna try and reschedule my
meeting
i feel kind of bad but
for the person i'm supposed to meet with
if you're watching right now
uh let's reschedule hopefully for some
time later this week
i hope you understand
so e5
wait is it a hundred game match or is it
is it the first to 100
because those are very different things
thank you pakmanship
do
okay that's not so bad
okay we both won connect four
so who wins
oh so tricky
let's expand my connect four
all the way up the board let's get a new
type of
never mind
i guess he wins i'm going to connect for
his survived for longer
i defend
this and rookie 6.
this might just be a draw actually after
queen e5
draw
okay ortho schnapp time we played this
earlier and worked out really well
i'll play d4 this time
h4 greek gift ideas
so i probably want to castle queenside
i'm not scared of d4
[Music]
only open things up
okay i can't castle queenside
somehow it's not so simple
my castle king side
oh that's a good move though
okay i'm not castling anyway
i don't know if he can take this because
rook g1 rook g6 you think he's a better
chess player overall
you're levi
it's close call we're very close
our feed a ratings are similar our
leachat's bullet ratings are similar
but right now i'm higher rated than him
so
[Music]
numbers speak the truth right
um
okay i was dirty but nights are tricky
in these time scrambles
okay
yeah the home turf advantage
it's something right
although levy has won most of the time
scrambles this match
goat bit spa
also quack also hawk
oh thanks for that
nerd of many things
okay i'll play off five
so i'm up three games in the match
or no i'm up two games
a long ways to go
[Music]
this really tests like min uh mental
endurance physical endurance
composure under pressure
e3 might fall never mind
okay setting up some blockade
b5 i'll play g6
so i want to take taken
wow good move
this is actually okay
let's give away the queen
threatening made in one
second trimester here we come
here we come
queen do you want to play this move
still threatening maiden two
win the queen
turning the fork
no
yes
i feel so dirty
i feel so dirty
but also so happy
okay rematch
so keeping my lead
yeah heart rate pog
okay london time
oh my plans aren't working this game
but i still have a unpleasant position
i want my queen and bishop to switch
places
need some g3 idea
[Music]
94 idea
oh it's getting weird again
i just hung a rook but
this is such a mess
oh no my bishop
wow
that's a good move
because i have to take and take
it's still really tricky though
get the knight in
no trades
let's check
oh that was a mouse
up no
[Music]
had some chances there too but what to
do
okay this is already looking really nice
right before
because e3 is hanging
what is this
i think i want a pawn i want a couple of
pawns in the processor
am i losing a pawn knight a7
okay active king
yeah bishop trade just to simplify
things
white's knight is completely trapped
it was about to be
[Music]
but for who
how do i get the knight to check the
king
there we go
there we go
that was a confusing end game man
lights are so weird
and majestic
okay 1513
ponziani time
no ponziani
we'll play classical
i'm liking the position now
[Music]
idea h4h5
can take
now let's keep pushing
trying to apply maximum pressure
wow
queen b7
that didn't quite work the way i wanted
it to
good move
oh no
my rook
hey it's merch
purchase that's new
hey it's a queen i'm still down at rook
though
[Music]
okay some progress
i've triple pawns somehow
there we go
i feel dirty about this game but what to
do
what to do okay
that's the nature of bullet
i feel really dirty
i want to play one of these uh jonathan
shawn's gambits
let's let's try uh let's try this one
again
c4906
it's uh
he's not allowing it
reverse london
reverse london
it's probably dubious but it's
interesting
and this is everything you hope and
dream of from a
black side london
except my bishop is not so
dreamy
this
i just got forks
okay it's a counter fork
some momentum for me
wow look at these pawns
this should be pretty straightforward
okay wow what a game that was a cool
position
press enter to focus
nah
oh press enter to focus haha
okay
let's play uh
well with a6 i can't really do what i
want to do
okay this is where i really want to just
clamp down
[Music]
show no mercy wow he won connect five
am i trapping the queen
not quite
but i have nice development
okay g6 is a bit tender also c4
i'll try and win both of them
a very few
a legal move
queenside castling
very surprising
but i very much welcome the king joining
the party
other pieces are not invited
okay
1813.
this match started
a bit differently
uh he knows all my england gambit stuff
i think h6
idea this
maybe g5 bishop g7
okay
this is reasonable
queen
my king should be on f8 actually
woo
ah i see his plan
oh no my
ah he queen take it
okay so i'm off a piece
temporarily
i miss rook d i miss rook to eh
this is still winning though
or is it no it's not winning
but actually my queen
oh
i feel so bad now
oh and this rook d8 ah
also missed the fact my queen could be
taken
up four games
no time for getting tilted though
okay
this is some opening preparation
not sure how impressive it is but
uh
i shouldn't trade queens here
play queen b3
i'm treating this as a gambit
i'm not sure how much compensation there
is
maybe there's something
idea rook c7
idea knight c6 now
okay going for the rook lift
ic5 good move
wait how am i down the exchange
when did i lose a rook
i'm so confused
that's ooh that's a bad move
this should be a draw
okay at least i didn't lose that
when did i lose exchange that game
oh he just took my rook on c3 okay
oh it's a fatigue setting in
okay
play this one again
actually let's play uh reverse london
against this
a solid approach
queen b8
he's quick for knight e5
play a4 or a5
going for a4
oh i didn't see the queen was attacked
but thankfully
it was defended
that's a good move
i'm taking king f8
i come back in the tag e3
so not really time to take on h7
interesting
oh
yeah he's so clever
um all my pawns disappear
okay
yeah he was very clever that game like
super resourceful
is he going to play oh this f6 line
yeah this is a thing these days
it's funny how we kind of share a
similar preparation
let me take
i'm casting a take
that's clever
actually maybe it's okay
oh it's not okay
you missed uh i still defend e2 so
there's no mate
i was very closely i made it there
i got forked
my hoodie oh yes
oh no my knight
this is so uncomfortable
oh i almost came back and then i didn't
okay 16 and a half
can't complain with this also thank you
good charlie brown for
getting some hoodie
yeah this is looking pretty good already
queen b7 94 bishop
wait what
it's interesting attempt
hey it's tactics
oh no my queen for the triple fork
good move lovey's a fighter
but i'm a forker
okay
carol khan
purits play this line
something that resembles ponziani
at this point i'm just trying to get a
time advantage
difficult position though
okay threatening the pawn
okay somehow the momentum is shifting
pawn is loose
bye
okay
i just say focus there man
palms are getting cold and also sweaty
oh gotham says ggs
okay ggs
okay good games levy
oh
yeah 100 games would have been excessive
i think
but uh
that was fun i hope people enjoyed it
had some dirty games
i feel bad about some of them but
i hope people enjoy the content
not every day we get to
play such a fun match
and a long match